est ce que christian calçada est capable
de prendre la fuite est ce qu'il est
capable d'être en cavale merci pascal
heureux d'être avec nous vous êtes type
l'analyste en soi est ce qu'on a déjà
d'autres éléments de la sphère gay aux
jantes oui alors on soupçonne que les
sentiers sanaa d'être en cavale or être
en cavale ça coûte énormément d'argent
et selon nos informations christian
quesada contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser n'a plus beaucoup
d'argent on a tout le détail ce qui est
selon nos informations christian quesada
a obtenu un prêt détail de ses dépenses
regard des crises en quesada il a gagné
et 600000 euros de gains aux 12 coups de
midi
il a donné trois cent mille euros à ses
deux enfants il a donné 80 mille euros à
son frère il a acheté un studio on l'a
dit hier 30 millions à béziers 150000
euros dans des voyages c'est un énorme
fan de voyager des parties notamment en
asie la chirurgie des dons il s'est fait
refaire les dents 15000 euros il lui
reste 25 mx chez moi vous avez souri
bourgoin c'est un axe annoncé sa
déclaration au juge c'est vraiment des
chiffres très exact il lui reste que
25000 euros sur les six en tout cas les
généraux avec sa famille voilà il n'a
plus de sources de revenus aujourd'hui
que sans qu'elle s'en défende la green
castle
oui justement ce cadre ne veut merci
d'être là alors déjà ce que vous pouvez
nous décrire le profil psychologique de
christian quesada parce que série que je
le connais pas bien son nom mais vous
connais moi de ce que vous avez vu parce
que c'est vrai que c'est incroyable de
passer d'une telle ou telle personnalité
de ce coup de midi je vous l'avais déjà
dit un mois à l'époque je voulais même
construire un jour ne lui mets questions
qu'ils avaient quand on a appris voilà
voilà la face sombre de côté sombre et
très sombre de christian quesada on est
vraiment tombé des nues en fait on était
à ses fans on va pas se mentir quand on
l'a reçu ce soir ce plateau il ya
personne aussi sur le plateau requis ses
doutes elle ne serait ce que l'ombre
d'un instant qu'ils avaient une part de
nombreux chez ce garçon si ce monsieur
alors voulu c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est ce qu'on appelle les mythomanes
les gens qui croient effectivement dans
leur mensonge alors il n'y a pas ça
rentre pas dans des catégories
psychiatrique même dans le dsm qui est
le gros livre de l'om est selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
concernant la psychiatrie terre que ce
sont les troubles relationnels
narcissique avec des gens qui sont dans
la toute puissance qui se pensent
totalement différent et c'est quelqu'un
qui m'apparaît en tout cas paraître pour
être présent sur les plateaux télé faire
tout et n'importe quoi et surtout faire
ensuite perpétue l'on parlait lui c'est
ça et donc il est là dedans alors penser
que ses collègues et ses 6 ha oui pour
moi oui c'est sûrement narcissique il a
raison le monsieur bernard montiel
[Rires]
j'ai gardé et en fait il aurait préparé
justement cette fuite peut être aussi
pour refaire parler de lui d'une autre
manière
mais comme lâchait dupont de ligonnès au
lui ment ligonnès on ne sait pas ce qui
s'est passé et c'est il ya beaucoup de
débats j'ai fait plein d'émissions sur
le sujet je le connais très bien
papa lui mais en tout cas le sujet sujet
et voilà ils ont envie de faire parler
d'eux de manière perpétuelle
ils ont un ego hyper centré sur vous
pensez qu à la limite tout ce qui lui
est arrivé il se considère comme un bon
on peut pas dire mais lui ça comme un
héros comme un ici c'est un héros mais
en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui est
intelligent il avait quand même réussi
énormément de choses avaient été ré mai
mais ensuite effectivement ils ont cette
intelligence et cette faculté à duper
les autres et à manipuler saint-amarin
plater absolument c'est vrai mais parce
qu'on a dit c'est pour ça que c'est
réussir ce qu'il est en train de faire
réussir une cavale il faut être surtout
quand on voit la lui connaît on peut
parier que 25000 euros vous n'allez pas
très loin non plus 25000 euros
mais la question mais en prenant la
lumière comme ça à l'époque sur ce jeu
et il se doutait bien qu'il prenait un
risque quand même que que des gens le
reconnaissent et et réagissent parce
qu'il est sur un super ego donc pas quoi
qu'il en soit ils sont absolument pas
content du tout le monde et c'est là où
son côté manipulateur ou l'amène à faire
tout et n'importe quoi où il jouit entre
en quelque sorte du fait de manipuler
absolument tout ça de duper
et studio les plateaux télé isabelle oui
et puis il n'avait pas usurpé son rôle
dans la mesure où il nous a donné plein
de trucs donc on n'a pas gratter
derrière il disait qu'il avait été sdf
il disait qu'il était tombé dans la
drogue il disait qu'il était il avait
obtenu la garde de ses fils mais que
c'était dur donc et nous fournissait
plein d'informations on n'avait aucune
raison d'aller gratter derrière c'est
quand même un bon destin moi ce qui me
dérange beaucoup c'est ce qu'on a
découvert par la suite du registre de la
paix doc massa 6e assez c'est ça que les
gens mais en revanche j'ai un côté
obscur bien sûr extrêmement meilleur
abjecte et comme moi condamné et comme
il a quitté le sud de la france et les
environs de perpignan sans laisser d
adresse là les enquêteurs qui se sont
remis aujourd'hui se demande si il ne
veut pas leur lancer un nouveau défi
c'est pas moi la serez vous capable de
me retrouver face et la question croyez
qu'il est dans un jeu là dans une sorte
de jeu de réalité virtuelle qu'il se
crée lui même ont brouillé une nouvelle
fois les pistes tiffany excusez moi je
comprends pas mais vous êtes sûr de ça
on n'est pas en train de fantasmer une
cavale là et on sait ce que c'est sur de
simples parce que et ce qui n'est pas
juste tout simplement en train de faire
profil bas il n'a pas forcément envie
qu'on met en avant sa fresque pervers
cela et il change de look pour passer
inaperçu il en bisbille avec les
policiers ils savent très bien où il est
c'est tout non gestion importante est ce
que parce que je suis très inquiet mois
qu'ils soient en cavale et ce qui
pourrait récidiver à votre avis est ce
qu'ils oseraient récit on peut pas
savoir
on est sur des projections sur des
prospectives on peut jamais deviné et on
voit très bien sur plein de 2,2 de
terrain criminelle c'est après coup
effectivement qu'on se dit mais
effectivement c'était lui et on
soupçonne est absolument rien qui
pourrait oser aujourd'hui avec tout cela
on fait justement rien je peux encore
absolument pas le définir
guillot moi j'ai appelé l'organisme qui
est chargée d'effectuer des contrôles
judiciaires de caissons quesada au bout
de 15 à peine ils m'ont répondu ils sont
extrêmement agacé pour la situation ils
m'ont dit aucun commentaire appelé le
ministre de la justice lui seul a le
droit de dire oui quesada ils sont très
agacés et en colère contre eux quesada
donc ça veut bien dire qu'il ya un
problème avec lui en tout cas révélé
mélicie qui sont chez lui c'est faux ce
n'est pas normal
suite à sa libération les policiers
n'ont pas aller chez quesada alors
gilles vous avez également des infos
pour vous il essaie de laisser vraiment
disparaître comme on l'a dit hier lors
où il ya une volonté claire de ne pas
laisser de traces d'avoir une nouvelle
domiciliation tout est fermé
parti il ne répond pas aux convocations
les policiers recherchent donc oui il ya
une volonté de disparaître totalement
il faut rappeler que si les rattraper
après avoir rompu cent sur trois ans de
prison à trois 3 ans de prison ouais
c'est à grand chose mais un mythomane
quoi qu'il en soit il a trois options à
tuer les autres se suicider disparaître
non mais c'est pas cool qui s'y passe et
c'est la raison c'est la folie oui là sa
palette mais en tout cas c'est une
psychopathologie
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
fascine tous parce qu'on va les suivre
on va continuer à leur donner ma
distance orthopédie sont morts en tout
cas j'espère que la justice n'est pas
trompés à l'appel une bouffée délirante
ce que super g a récidivé sur la période
alors j'ai eu un petit fou rire il ya un
instant parce que sachez que le nom
d'eddie kim a fait un portrait robot de
questions qui sanaa à quoi ça quoi il
pourrait ressembler aujourd'hui sachez
qu'en prison tout le monde le sont
nommés robinson et robinson crusoé par
ses co détenus
et il aurait aujourd'hui les cheveux
longs et une épaisse barbe regarde c'est
jésus c'est pas de total n'ont pas peur
mais là c'est vrai c'est pas une fête de
tous les mecs à ya pas de fans
excusez-moi
voilà c'est donc nouveau détecté ce à
quoi ressemblera aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment tendu nous faut détecter
je sais pas une bonne du tout voilà
voilà donc c'était l'info keziah
s'adonne l'indiqué mais bien sûr mais je
dirais que c'est drôle c'est quand même
un certain mais bon pas tout de suite
c'est pourquoi tu dis papa c'est pas
immédiats immédiat